element puls
wieder einmal war ja ihr habt auch den
titel gelegt weil euch das thema
brennend interessiert warum bin ich fett
geworden und nein das ist kein klick
baic ich werde euch heute den grund
verraten warum ich zugenommen habe ich
muss jetzt auch schon verraten es ist
kein grund der wirklich großartig
traurig macht uns der fakt dass ich
zugenommen habe macht mich auch nicht
traurig in dem zusammenhang natürlich
hätte ich wieder gerne eines zusammen
aber ich habe über die letzten monate
ungefähr zehn kilo zugenommen
es hat einen grund ich habe das ganze
jahr an einem projekt gearbeitet
ich kann ich euch sagen ich hab euch
auch schon vorhersagen kann ich weiß
aber ich dachte wenn ich es euch sage
dann möchte ich auch gleich sagen in der
infobox findet ihr den link zu meinem
kochbuch sie können gerne diesen link
benutzen weil dann bekomme ich noch von
amazon will ea und so benutzt gerne
diesen link wenn ihr mich unterstützen
wollt ihr ein geschmeckt kochbuch haben
wollt dann könnt ihr ab heute es
vorgestellt das erscheinungsdatum ist
der 29
ich weiß es ist noch eine ecke hin aber
es muss natürlich nachgedruckt werden
und ganz viel kram und ja so krass ist
es so krass ich das endlich sagen zu
können ich mir gerade was das für eine
erleichterung ist und wie ich happy bin
dass ich jetzt überlebt habe und was es
jetzt mit fett geworden sein zutun hat
nun ja ich habe den kompletten sommer im
weg gestanden und food fotos gemacht
und da ich nicht nur hell wie wiegen
salate gemacht habe sondern halt auch
torten und kuchen und bieten das habe
ich das natürlich danach auch immer
gegessen weil ich das ja nicht
wegschmeißen wollte es manche sachen
habe ich dann meinem netzwerk gebracht
oder irgendwelchen freundin gegeben aber
die haupt also das meiste habe ich
einfach gegessen
bin ich jetzt auch mal ganz ehrlich mit
euch bricht aber ja nur für das kochbuch
ich kann euch jetzt schon verraten es
lohnt sich wirklich
das zu kaufen ich würde es mir selber
kaufen es in viele rezepte dabei die es
hier bei mir schmeckt auch schon gab
aber es gibt auch ganz ganz viele neue
und natürlich möchte dieses video nutzen
um euch einerseits zu sagen ihr könnt es
ab jetzt bestanden also falls sie auf
dieses wie schmeckt buch gewartet habt
weil sie ein kochbuch haben wollt zu
rezepten aus film und serien oder wenn
ihr mich auch unterstützen wollt ihr
könnt es euch jetzt holen und ich möchte
auch natürlich gleich die chance nutzen
um euch zu erzählen wie die ganze reise
also bisher so war und wie man so ein
kochbuch macht und was alles so passiert
ist
und ja okay jetzt jetzt geht es wieder
jetzt bin ich jetzt ist raus die bombe
ist geplatzt
mein gott formaten wie schmeckt solltet
ihr wahrscheinlich alle kennen und das
habe ich ja vor ungefähr zweieinhalb
jahren gestartet damals als erstes mit
dem schneewittchen kuchen
ich bin ziemlich aufgeregt denn ich habe
mir ein format überlegt was ich ziemlich
cool finde was ab heute starten wird
das ganze heißt wie schmeckt und dann
hab ich butterbier mit keller gemacht
und dann habe ich ganz vielen anderen
kram gemacht und mir ist damals
überhaupt nicht klar gewesen dass es ein
sehr beliebtes format war also es war es
kann schon gut an aber es war jetzt
nicht so dass sich auch der ersten folge
gemerkt hat
geschmeckt machtvoll viele klicks oder
es folgt rus kommt bei euch gut an
es war halt wirklich einfach nur so ich
mochte die idee und dann wollte ich es
auch machen und dann über die zwei jahre
ist natürlich mega abgegangen
die videos haben teilweise über eine
million über zwei millionen klicks
irgendwann vor einem jahr hat es dann
angefangen dass mir viele geschrieben
haben doch mal ein kochbuch und jetzt
bringen wir die rezepte raus weilt in
den videos koche ich aber ich koche halt
auch immer nach frei schnauze also ich
hatte in den meisten fällen nicht wo ich
sagen kann so ok und dann so genau so
funktioniert weil das aber natürlich
viel arbeit ist alle schritte auf zu
schreiben bzw auch wenn ich dann gemerkt
hat während des videos wenn ich was
gekocht habe und dann ist es nichts
geworden und dann musste ich was
verändern das will ich mir halt nie
notiert deswegen gab es nie so richtig
rezepte dazu ja und dann von einem jahr
ist so dass die entscheidung gefallen
dass das kochbuch kommt und dass ich das
machen will dann hatte ich die ersten
gespräche mit meinem verlag community
edition sei
und dann haben wir groß darüber
gesprochen was ist sein kann wie man es
aufbauen kann welche kategorien man rein
nimmt also so ein großes konstrukt
gebaut und dann habe ich schon gemerkt
okay so ein kochbuch ist auf jeden fall
mehr arbeit als ich mir vorgestellt und
dann bin ich halt noch keinen gefahren
dann wurde alles final entschieden und
dann ging es halt auch ganz schnell wie
sie das layout aus wie soll das teil
sein ich meine es gibt ja nur so kannst
es im landhaus dir machen du kannst ein
sehr modernes und minimalistisches
kochbuch gestalten und da muss man halt
wirklich erstmal selber wissen was man
möchte und ich sag's mal vorweg ich bin
mit dem ergebnis sehr zufrieden
ich habe alle entscheidungen getroffen
ich habe natürlich auch hilfe von der
grafikerin bekommen der verlag hat
natürlich auch tipps gegeben und und
ihre meinung immer mit rein gebracht
aber im endeffekt ging alles durch meine
hand
mit durch ist jetzt nicht so dass ich
ein fertiges layout bekommen habe und
dann entscheiden konnte ob mir gefällt
das am meisten ich möchte das nicht habe
da wirklich ideen mit reingepackt
mitgestaltet ich saß bei photoshop und
hat versucht das irgendwie so
zusammenzubasteln dass am ende cool
aussieht und zusammen der grafikerin
konnte man dann etwas erschaffen was
professionell aussieht aber auch meinem
kopf entspricht und ein riesen teil des
projekts war das erste mal sich für
rezepte zu entscheiden es gibt hier
schon ein paar geschmeckt folgen und da
gab es auf jeden fall derzeit bin ich
auf jeden fall in dem buch haben will
aber es sollte natürlich auch etwas
neues geben und dann gab es natürlich
das nächste problem und zwar wie macht
man fotos haben natürlich alle schon mal
für instagram unserer frische
fotografiert oder man teller geschickt
und gezeigt wie toll man kochen kann
aber ich habe noch nie zuvor ein gut
ausgeleuchtet das foto gemacht was man
drucken kann jetzt gibt's schon kleine
spoiler und zwar habe ich das kochbuch
mit einer person gemacht und zwar
benjamin blümchen meinem kameramann er
und ich haben daran zu zweit gearbeitet
benjamin wusste nicht wie man fotos
macht und ich auch nicht jemand erst mal
einen test shooting gemacht und haben
geschaut worauf es ankommt dann haben
wir eine neue lampe geholt eine größere
bessere riesen lampe die in dieser
kleinen wohnung sehr viel platz wegnimmt
kita wurde
wer braucht schon ein solarium wenn er
eine 150 meter lampard wie groß ist
und von diesem test shooting gab es dann
test drucke ich bin so aufgeregt
[Musik]
ich fühle mich wie so ein richtiger
buchautor
ich habe die ersten samples von meinem
ersten bilder und ruhe wird ich weiß es
wahrscheinlich nicht alle bilder benutzt
werden es ist ja nur teststudien gewesen
aber das sind sie das ist mein absolutes
lieblings bild vielleicht könnt ihr
erraten was es sein könnte
auf jeden fall war es sehr anstrengend
ist schade dass wir das des shooting
nicht mit gefilmt haben
und da ist uns auf jeden fall
aufgefallen dass wir noch ganz viel
lernen mussten weil wir ganz viel falsch
gemacht haben haben wir dann alles auch
gelernt haben wir dann auch alles
angewendet und leute ich kann euch jetzt
aus erfahrung sagen für ein komplettes
kochbuch rezepte zu erstellen die sachen
zu kochen und zu fotografieren ist sehr
sehr sehr viel arbeit bevor man damit
überhaupt anfangen kann muss man die kuh
kaufen und versteht mich nicht falsch
ich liebe natürlich ein shopping ausflug
zu butlers und depot und wie sie nicht
alle heißen
aber wenn du für über 60 fotos
dekorationen brauchst dann wirst du
wahnsinnig
[Musik]
ich habe immer versucht mir im kopf
dieses foto vorzustellen es sollte ja
auch immer zu dem rezept passend zu der
serie oder zu dem film und darauf wollte
ich dann diego kaufen das ist super
super 8 es ist fast unmöglich sich für
über 60 rezepte die bilder im kopf
vorzustellen sie sollten natürlich auch
mal zum thema passen vom film oder von
der serie ich habe viel viel geld für
dekoration ausgegeben und das ist ja
nicht nur deko ist wenn ja dann auch
noch untergründe und holzplanken wir
fahren zum wertstoffhof denn wir waren
nachschauen ob die neue untergründe
finden und nicht so viel geld dafür
ausgeben müssen und chemiewehr der fall
man kann nicht auf dem bild er hof
mitnehmen also die leute können da hat
ihr altholz hinbringen aber man darf es
nicht einfach nehmen
ich mache jetzt einen hintergrund und
dafür habe ich eine kündigung holzplatte
geholt denn gebraucht natürlich für die
fotos viele verschiedene untergründe
wende
[Musik]
so war es zum beispiel für das schönste
super altmodisch aus hat auch viel geld
gekostet das problem ist dass man zum
beispiel in berlin an alt heute und so
nicht gut ankommt weil das ist einfach
das hips der material nummer eins und es
kostet super viel geld wenn ich jetzt zu
hause bei meinen eltern wäre dann wisst
ihr dass im gartenhaus 100 holzplanken
sind die platzen kann aber hier
natürlich etwas hat natürlich auch spaß
gemacht durch die leben zu schlendern
und wahllos geld auszugeben für scheiß
den man später nicht mehr brauche weil
ich auch ein paar rezepte aus dem
asiatischen anime bereich haare mussten
wir an asiatische lebensmittel kommen
und ich bin das erste mal im dong xuan
center in lichtenberg gewesen das ist
hier auch in berlin ich habe dort mit
benjamin einen kompletten tag verbracht
und im endeffekt aber ich wieder so viel
geld ausgegeben für zeug was ich wieder
nicht gebraucht habe und jetzt habe ich
auch ganz viele asiatische lebens mit
seitdem haben sich mir auch meine
asiatischen koch skills verbessert also
ich mache jetzt erst einmal so eine
schöne misosuppe weil ich ganz viel
davon herr aber das werdet ihr dann im
kochbuch sehen was da so an asiatischen
dingen drin sind ich weiß das video wird
schon wieder viel zu lang jetzt war es
nämlich an der zeit die fotos zu machen
und sich dabei rezepte auszudenken ihr
wisst ja dass der sommer ziemlich heißen
ziemlich lang war und ich habe diesen
sommer komplett in der küche verbracht
vielleicht ist das jetzt auch meckern
auf hohem niveau und ich bin ein
leidender schwan der nichts aushält ein
bisschen stress und ich falle um aber es
war so anstrengend ich bin jeden tag um
5.30 aufgestanden habe es 36 kw getrogen
gefrühstückt und alles bin dann in den
supermarkt gefahren und habe für drei
rezepte eingekauft dann wenn ich nach
hause gefahren habe angefangen zu kochen
habe an
fangen mit benjamin fotos zu machen
kochen fotos kochen fotos und um
ungefähr 21 22 uhr waren wir meistens
fertig ja vielleicht gibt es leute die
schneller kochen können und es besser
machen können aber es war unser erstes
mal und ich bin sehr stolz dass wir das
überhaupt geschafft haben drei rezepte
am tag zu fotografieren für über zwei
monate aber eigentlich hat auch die
ganze zeit spaß gemacht es gab so ein
paar tage dazwischen wo ich meine mal
morgens aufgestanden bin und dachte man
ist diese höllenfahrt vorbei
lesen krankenhaus in der praxis aber
dann gab es auch andere tage wo man
irgendwas gekocht hat und es hingestellt
hat und ein foto gemacht hat und es
einfach so gut aussah dass sogar standes
und dachte das habe ich gemacht
[Musik]
ob es in die kamera hält und dass du so
anfängt so hat sich gewundert hat warum
ich so wie ich es gemacht habe
ich hab's gemacht hatte steht mir nicht
meinen weg ich habe und ich muss sagen
diese tage haben einen dann immer wieder
so gepusht dass man gesagt hat ja jetzt
erst richtig jetzt kam nie richtig cool
photos und für das nächste foto machen
wir wissen das und dann machen wir das
so und so aber das wird cool aussehen
und dann gab es natürlich wieder die
tage wohl nichts klappen wollte und man
einfach nur sich verstecken wollte in
einem loch innerhalb der kürzesten zeit
bin ich so über mich hinausgewachsen
dass ich teilweise dachte passiert das
gerade wirklich koch und fotografiere
ich gerade wirklich für mein kochbuch
und es war so nervend aufreiben neben
den youtube-videos das kochbuch zu
erstellen also mein hauptberuf ist ja
youtuber zu sein und videos regelmäßig
zu produzieren und sie online zu stellen
aber diese kochens irgendwie anders
es ist nicht so dass ich mit jemandem
zusammengearbeitet habe und immer nur
gesagt hab ja das möchte ich so und das
gefällt mir so und jetzt steht er mein
name drauf kauft euch meine neue box
sondern es ist komplett und vanessa hat
all die energie und zeit in dieses buch
eingepackt und nebenbei noch versucht
youtube videos zu machen und das den
zuschauer nicht auffällt dass ich
eigentlich gar keine zeit für videos
habe ich die gerne zum kochen bringen
die ganze zeit nur am telefonieren
rezepte erstellen sie sonst aus und ich
bin dann wisst ihr was ich bin einfach
megastolz auf mich an immer von mir
gedacht dass ich ein mittelmäßiger
mensch bin und nicht immer
negativen sinne ich dachte nur immer
dass mein leben und ich und was ich
schaffe immer im mittelmaß bleiben wird
dass ich nichts erreiche was so heraus
schlecht weil ich auch schon so in der
schule war ich habe mich für tests nur
kurz vorher vorbereitet und ich habe
immer alles gut geschafft und ich wusste
wenn ich mehr arbeit reinstecken würde
dann würde ich einen viel besser
notendurchschnitt haben und aber so war
mein leben irgendwie ich meine ich habe
schuhgröße 39 ich bin 168 groß ich wiege
jetzt ein bisschen mehr ich verrate ich
das nicht ich war immer so mittelmaß und
es ist nichts schlechtes das finde ich
hier noch einmal ganz groß betonen wenn
man kein kochbuch rausbringen und
mittelmäßig ist und das leben nur
mittelmäßiges dann ist es nicht schlimm
ich hätte nur nie von mir gedacht dass
ich aus meiner eigenen lebenseinstellung
heraustreten kann und sagen kann ich
schaffe jetzt mehr es klingt mega wird
aber es hieß für eine ganz lange zeit
dass sich so viel selbstdisziplin
brauche und immer wieder aus so tiefs
raus musste um zu sagen es ist gerade
super anstrengend und ich fühle mich
gerade komplett überfordert aber ich
kämpfe mich da durch weil ich das ziel
erreichen will so weich halten wenn mir
etwas zu anstrengend vor kamen dann habe
ich es dann doch lieber sein lassen
einfach nur um nummer sicher zu gehen
hat nichts riskieren dass ich meine egal
weiter im text wir haben dann nach den
zwei monate fotoshooting alle fotos
abgegeben rezept abgegeben dann gab es
eine million telefonate um irgendwas zu
klären hier wie viele personen das ist
wie viel gramm hast du das wirklich so
gemeint hast du das nicht so gemeint
ja ja nie weiß ich nicht scheiße ich
hab's vergessen zu notieren so ne ganze
spaß war danach und preises irgendwann
mal ein zweites kochbuch geben wird weiß
ich jetzt schon ganz viele dinge die ich
vorher nicht wusste da könnt ihr sicher
sein
oh ja hast noch mega viel spaß gemacht
hat war das fotoshooting für die
aufmacher seiten von den kategorien also
es wird er mehrere kategorien für dieses
buch geben und die seiten haben wir halt
geshootet da kann man mich ab und zu mal
sehen und wir waren dafür im
wir haben dabei studio 71 haben wir
fotos gemacht ich hatte meine eigene
maskenbildnerin die mich geschminkt hat
und ich habe mich an den ganzen tag so
super cool gefühlt und es war mal schön
da es jemand anderes das organisiert
hatte und sich darum gekümmert hat dass
es was wird weil bis dahin hab ich halt
zwei monate fotos gemacht und war so
dieses kochbuch ich muss mich um alles
kümmern und dann habe ich das für einen
tag abgeben können und jemand anderes
hat das organisiert und dann war ich so
cool ein tag pause hier ich kann grinsen
hallo hye ja
zeig mir den sexy lächeln ich habe mir
sogar tatsächlich dafür die haare färben
lassen weil ich mich sofern sie gefühlt
hat wer sich ein fotoshooting hat nun
kommen wir bei mir hat sich darum
gekümmert dass auch meine haare und
schön aussehen der tommy ist mein
friseur seit michael ja nach köln
gezogen ist musste ich ihn ja fremdgehen
und das war's jetzt
man kann das kochbuch vorbestellen könnt
ihr es glauben oder ich selbst auch
nicht nächstes jahr am 29 märz kommt es
raus ich wäre sehr happy wenn ihr dem
buch eine chance geben ihr könnt es euch
gerne gerne vorbestellen das cover wird
noch ein ganz bisschen verändert nicht
erschrecken wenn ihr es dann bekommt und
sagt es sei ein bisschen anders aus aber
das sind keine großartigen veränderungen
es wird noch ein bisschen cooler gemacht
und ja schreibt mir was ihr von der
ganzen sache haltet schreibt mir gerne
ob ihr euch das vorbestellen werde
ich habe gar keine ahnung wie das
ankommen wird ob es sich 50 leute
bestellen oder 1000 menschen
ich habe gar keine ahnung ich weiß es da
draußen viele wie schmeckt's fans gibt
und ich hoffe einfach dass es gut
ankommen wird ich hoffe einfach ja das
ist den leuten das buch gefällt dass
wenn ihr die rezepte nachgekocht dass
ihr die sachen lecker findet ich habe
alles selber erstellt stehe mit meinem
namen dafür dass dieses gute qualität
hat dafür stehe ich mit meinem namen und
das ist euch gefallen wird und dass sehr
viel arbeit dahinter steckt und dass ich
einfach sehr happy bin dass man das
jetzt bestellen kann
ihr könnt natürlich jetzt nicht mit
meinem link bestellen ihr könnt
natürlich auch beim thalia vorbestellen
oder im buchladen des vertrauens könnt
ihr auch hingehen und sagen hey bestehe
man bitte nicht vor
ja das wollte sagt den link und ich mach
jetzt direkt auf wissen sie was ich habe
gar kein sekt hier das video gerne mit
euren geschmeckt freunden und gibt einen
daumen nach oben schreibt etwas nettes
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
video eure buch autorin vanessa
sk